Popular TV series can become victims of their
own success.
Cast and crew make such compelling television
that some fans just can't wait to find out
what happens next on their favorite shows,
and will go to any length to get that information.
That's why some productions have tried to
thwart these spoilers at great effort and
expense by actually scripting and filming
scenes they never even intend to use.
Here's a look at shows that tried to throw
off the spoilers with fake footage.
And of course, real spoilers ahead…
The Sopranos
The Sopranos had one of the most famous — and
maddening — final moments in TV history.
As gangster Tony Soprano sits in a diner with
members of his family and Journey's "Don't
Stop Believing" plays on the jukebox, the
scene abruptly cuts to black, mid-scene.
Many viewers assume that the sudden ending
reflects Tony Soprano's fate — that he was
killed by one of his many enemies.
In the decade since The Sopranos wrapped up,
creator David Chase has been reluctant to
spell out exactly what became of Tony, but
in 2016, he told Deadline that he shot a different
ending because the production had experienced
problems with "people trying to invade and
get our scripts."
The scene was shot, but the details were so
inconsequential — and destined to be discarded
as a ruse — that Chase couldn't even remember
all the details.
He tried to recall: "Tony goes back to the
Bada Bing strip club and has an argument with
Silvio or something.
Well, it couldn't have been because he was
in the hospital.
Well, anyway, it was a fake ending that we
shot just to throw people off."
Lost
John Locke, played by Terry O'Quinn met a
sad fate on Lost, horrifically strangled to
death by Michael Emerson’s Ben Linus.
But the show played fast and loose with time
and space, so Locke was still part of the
series even after the revelation that the
body in the casket in the funeral parlor was
his.
Or maybe not: After a major plot in which
Locke led a group looking to take down Jacob,
his body was shown rolling out of a cargo
box.
Heroic Leader Locke was actually the shape-shifting
Man in Black, and the real Locke was dead.
To throw everybody for a loop, or maybe to
keep their options open, the Lost crew shot
a couple of other scenes, in which the dead
man in the coffin isn't Locke, but Sawyer
and Desmond instead.
"He was a man of faith.
He was… a much better man than I will ever
be.”
Sex and the City
HBO's Sex and the City was an updated, urban
take on the romantic comedy, but a romantic
comedy nonetheless, and it ended like one:
Sarah Jessica Parker’s character, Carrie
Bradshaw wound up with her on-again, off-again
guy, Mr. Big, and returned to New York after
a spell in Paris.
The day after the finale aired in 2004, Parker
told USA Today that three different endings
had been shot, with the one true wrap-up kept
a secret.
The abandoned endings, which Parker called
"just silly," involved Carrie returning to
New York alone — or with artist boyfriend
Aleksandr Petrovsky.
Imagine the fan uproar if that happened.
Dallas
A massive hit during the 1979 to 1980 TV season,
the CBS primetime drama Dallas entranced millions
with the story of wicked Texas oil tycoon
J.R. Ewing, played by Larry Hagman and his
family and associates.
In the cliffhanger third season finale, as
J.R. got ready for bed one night…someone
shot him and left him for dead.
[Gunshot]
It was a shocking TV moment, and over the
summer, seemingly all of America debated "Who
shot J.R.?" — as pretty much every character
on Dallas had a motive.
So to keep fans guessing in case a cast or
crew member leaked the details, multiple resolutions
to the cliffhanger were shot.
So who really shot J.R.? Turns out it was
his mistress and sister-in-law, Kristin Shepard
portrayed by Mary Crosby.
The Simpsons
Fifteen years after "Who Shot J.R.?," the
sixth season of The Simpsons ended with a
similar cliffhanger episode, in which Springfield
Nuclear Power Plant boss C. Montgomery Burns
is shot by an unidentified assailant and collapses
onto a sundial, with his arms pointed to the
"W" and "S." Pretty much everybody in Springfield
was a suspect, but in the seventh-season premiere,
infant Maggie Simpson was revealed as the
shooter.
While there were clues that the baby did it,
Simpsons writer David Mirkin told The A.V.
Club that he "purposely wanted to construct
it so that it made you think that Smithers
had done it."
As discussed on a Simpsons DVD commentary
track, scenes of many characters pulling the
trigger were created, including Moe, Barney,
and Santa's Little Helper.
To fool leakers further, a completely separate
ending was produced in which Smithers actually
did shoot Mr. Burns.
The Walking Dead
The sixth season of The Walking Dead built
up to the arrival of Negan, played by Jeffrey
Dean Morgan.
In the original comics written by Robert Kirkman,
Negan almost immediately kills Glenn with
Lucille, his barbed-wire wrapped baseball
bat.
Would the show follow suit, or would another
member of Rick's gang, ambushed by the Saviors,
meet their doom instead?
In the mid-season finale, Negan killed…somebody.
The show cut to black before we could find
out.
Viewers had to wait a while to learn that
Glenn and Abraham were indeed at the other
end of Lucille.
Showrunner Scott Gimple wanted to keep that
eventual outcome secret, which was especially
difficult because The Walking Dead deals with
incredibly bold and intrusive spoiler-hunters
— in fact, camera-equipped drones have been
spotted flying over the set.
In order to preserve the big reveal, the show
shot 11 different Lucille-related deaths scenes:
one for each character.
Game of Thrones
While The Walking Dead crew has to deal with
intrusive drones, Game of Thrones has to deal
with paparazzi using long-range camera lenses
to snap pictures of the show in progress.
In the lead up to the show's seventh season
in 2017, producers filmed fake scenes to fool
those tricky photographers and spoiler-hungry
fans.
Kit Harington, who stars as Jon Snow, told
Jimmy Kimmel that the series shot three scenes
that weren't part of the show or intended
to be used at all.
"We put together people in situations where
we knew the paparazzi was around, so they’d
take photos and that would get on the internet,
to fake scenes.”
For his part, Kimmel summed up what the process
must've been like for the cast and crew:
"What a pain in your ass that is.”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!